[Musique]
j'ai longtemps souffert de kako rafiot
phobies ou dati phobie c'est la même
chose
les deux noms sont incompréhensibles
c'est une peur anormal mais persistante
de l'échec
j'avais tellement peur de l'échec je
préférerais ne pas faire certaines
choses plutôt que risquer de les échoué
à cette époque je ne savais pas qu on
apprend beaucoup plus des échecs que des
succès je savais pas non plus que rodin
ce sculpteur de génie avait raté deux
fois le concours d'entrée aux beaux-arts
ni que jean paul belmondo n'avait pas pu
intégrer la comédie française il n'avait
pas le niveau
nick emmanuel macron avait raté trois
fois le concours d'entrée normale sup
par contre je savais qu'une chose un
échec me faisait très mal et je ne
voulais pas avoir mal alors pour éviter
d'avoir mal j'ai étudié le succès alors
je les ai étudié à fond
je voulais savoir comment les gens
obtiennent des succès comment ils font
pour réussir qui surtout évidemment est
ce qu'il ya un truc ben écoutez j'ai
découvert qu'il ya pas un truc il ya
plusieurs trucs
il ya trois trucs non y'a qu'la de trucs
pour réussir et j'en ai fait mon métier
je suis devenu dénicheur de succès et
d'ailleurs j'ai démarré mon métier ici
sur cette scène du palais des glaces où
j'ai découvert beaucoup de talent
notamment eric et ramzy jean marie
bigard et même gad elmaleh à ses débuts
je travaillais à l'époque pour universal
et j'avais découvert aussi des films
comme une suspecte ou des films comme
c'est arrivé près de chez vous ensuite
j'ai travaillé à tf1 et là j'ai
découvert des séries comme dr house les
experts des émissions comme danse avec
les stars
le film intouchables est ce que vantent
adancourt aujourd'hui l'émission the
voice
donc j'ai consacré toute ma vie au
succès mais pas aux miens j'ai consacré
ma vie au succès des autres et je vous
garantis que le succès ça s'apprend le
succès dépend de capter le travail le
talent la ténacité et le timing
il ya aussi la james bond la chance on
va enlever le thé donc le travail c'est
le premier thé c'est le plus
l'ingrédient le plus facile j'irai parce
qu'il dépend que de vous il dépend de
vous de votre volonté vous décider ou
pas de travailler et surtout il obéit
aux règles un peu déprimante mais
néanmoins qui est réel et qui a été
découvert par le psychologue ce fait
doit anders eriksson la règle des dix
mille heures si vous consacrez 10000
à pratiquer une activité quelle qu'elle
soit candy croche études de médecine
jogging tuning de vos voitures piano
cuisine vous atteindrez l'excellence
alors faites pas le cal que je le fais
pour vous en gros ça fait trois ans tous
les jours 10 heures par jour à 10 heures
de pratique il se passe des choses
géniales dans le cerveau les réactions
se modifie les connexions neuronales
accélère elles sont beaucoup plus fluide
elles sont plus efficaces et certaines
choses deviennent des habitudes par
contre un petit souci vous imaginez bien
que pour atteindre dix mille heures de
pratique c'est impossible si on n'aime
pas ce qu'on fait si on manque de goût
pour l'activité on peut pas pratiquer
dit miller c'est pour ça que le deuxième
ingrédient du succès le deuxième thé de
la formule c'est le talent on a un
talent pour quelque chose
on aime le faire en général des tout
petits et comme on aime le faire on peut
le pratiquer avec intensité et on
atteint les dix mille heures de pratique
sans souffrance sans trop de douleur je
dirais prenons quelqu'un comme andy
warhol à des peintres aujourd'hui les
plus appréciés du monde lui il dessinait
très mal il a passé dix mille heures pas
forcément à dessiner et aujourd'hui
c'est un des peintres les plus cotés du
monde
j'ai demandé à camille lacourt le très
beau blond très serré très baraqué
pardon cinq fois champion du monde de
natation
cinq fois champion d'europe je lui
demande du 10 mai mais comment tu
supportes des 10 km d'entraînement dans
un bassin alors il dit bah oui c'est pas
super agréable mais d'abord c'est un
entraînement et surtout il m'a dit pour
tenir
je me concentre sur un geste et le geste
j'ai décidé d'atteindre la perfection
dans ce geste donc il fait des longueurs
de bassin il fait des kilomètres par
jour
il faisait en tout cas avec ça là
jusqu'à atteindre la perfection du geste
alors pareil avec la jeunesse le talent
permet de démarrer un apprentissage
extrêmement tôt 100% des pilotes de
formule 1 et des champions ont démarré
par du karting et en général ils ont
démarré très jeune lewis hamilton le
plus grand champion de tous les temps
actuellement en course il a démarré à 8
ans tiger woods il a démarré le goal ça
deux ans picasso y des six ans il décide
est déjà extrêmement bien vous allez au
musée picasso des toiles entre 6 et 8
ans s'étaient déjà remarquable en plus
son père était prof de dessin
alors là vous commencez à vous dire
puisqu'ils m'ont raconté depuis dix
minutes
vous pensez que vous perdez votre temps
passez vous m'écoutez vous n'êtes pas
champion précoce vous n'êtes pas un
génie artistique où seraient pas
présents la république peu importe
rassurez-vous le talent précoce c'est
pas du tout une condition nécessaire
c'est même pas une condition suffisante
à la réussite
pensez à tous vos camarades de classe
dont les parents étaient extrêmement
fiers et les vôtres vous et ligne 1 qui
était très bon en gym en français et en
maths bas parmi tous ces enfants ces
anciens étudiants vous avez côtoyé
regarder lesquels ont vraiment réussi
moi personnellement et sur canal qui ont
réussi mais la plupart a été très bon en
maths en 6e et en 5e en quatrième et
jusqu'à la terminale et so what so pas
grand chose parce que manque d'ambition
et surtout parce que manque du troisième
temps que je vais vous dire maintenant
qui est le plus important des troisièmes
t c'est la ténacité
voilà tous les gens qui ont du succès
tous les gens qui ont réussi tous les
mecs qui sont passés ici qui ont réussi
et beaucoup ont raté mais ceux qui ont
réussi
je peux vous dire qu'ils avaient la
ténacité aujourd'hui par exemple un
exemple très incroyable vous voulez
lever des fonds à palo alto en
californie
il ya plein de gens qui veulent lever
des fonds ils vont voir dès 22h capital
et bien sur le cv de la personne qui
demande il faut qu' au moins trois
échecs pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que vous êtes relevé donc
trois fois puisque vous venez une
quatrième fois lever des fonds et la
deuxième raison c'est que vous avez les
dix mille heures de pratique parce que
si vous vous êtes planté trois fois
c'est que vous avez au moins galéré
pendant dix mille heures sur le dossier
donc le paradoxe est absolument
incroyable
alors que nous en france on rajoute des
trucs positifs sur nos cv pour faire
bien et souvent c'est des mensonges
eux ils rajoutent des trucs négatifs sur
leur cv pour faire bien donc il se
rajoute des échecs en essayant que les
échecs soit réaliste
c'est le monde à l'envers mais c'est
pourtant la réalité parce que les
américains tiennent à ce que les gens à
qui donne de l'argent et déjà eu des
échecs le lien entre succès et ténacité
a été démontrée démontré par la
professeure de psychologie angela dos
coiffe qui a fait un livre qui s'appelle
great gr i té donc ça veut dire la
niaque
elle l a pris des générations
d'étudiants et les gens qui avaient
réussi
elle a cherché le lien entre leur succès
est quelque chose eh bien la corrélation
est la causalité la plus efficace c'est
avec la ténacité dont qu'elle arrive à
prouver dans ce livre j'ai évidemment
lui que la ténacité c'est le seul vrai
critère qui permet de prédire le
succès d'un individu alors je vous
conseille de regarder un truc qui est
très amusant juste après quand vous
aurez vu cette conférence vous allez sur
internet et vous allez chercher le test
du chamallow
et là vous allez bien vous marier le
test du chamallow c'est une expérience
de ténacité qui est très amusante oppose
un chamallow devant un enfant jeune
entre 4 et 7 ans la table et là le
chamallow est là et quelqu'un en blouse
blanche suis dit voilà petit en anglais
donc je vous fais pas si tu tiens dix
minutes sans manger ce chamallows toner
à un deuxième or déjà le regard des
enfants si on dirait un petit chien que
c'est regarde comme ça mais faut qu'ils
tiennent dix minutes il y en a qui
jouent avec
il y en a même le plumard y en a qui le
lèche il le laisse comme ça il n'a pas
mangé personne n'a rien vu qui leur pose
comme ça par contre le test est un test
scientifique et le constat est
incroyable et ils ont fait l'étude sur
30 ans sur 30 ans
légende les enfants donc il y avait
entre 4 et 7 ans qui avait résisté aux
chamallows qui avait différé leur
plaisir pour en avoir un deuxième
eh bien ils ont mieux réussi que les
autres ce qui fait vraiment la
différence c'est ni le travail ni le
talent c'est la ténacité
parce que c'est un mélange de passion et
de persévérance on va parler du
quatrième t le quatrième t donc il est
cruel
c'est le plus cruel d'été parce que
c'est le seul tu es con contrôle pas
c'est le timing le timing c'est l'art
d'être là au bon moment alors ni trop
tôt ni trop tard en 1982 donc il ya quoi
il ya une quarantaine d'années
barry marshall et robin warren que vous
ne connaissez pas son deux chercheurs
australiens qui font des découvertes
extraordinaires ils découvrent que
l'ulcère de l'estomac qui fait vraiment
souffrir beaucoup de gens sur la planète
et provoqué par une minuscule bactéries
en forme de spirale donc comme ils ont
de l'humour ils l'ont rappelé hélico
bactéries pilori toute la communauté
médicale et scientifique se moque d'eux
et à l'époque personne ne croit que des
bactéries peuvent survivre dans un
environnement comme l'estomac
parce que l'estomac c'est trop acide en
désespoir de cause parce que barry
marshall était convaincu qu'il avait
raison et d'ailleurs il avait raison il
a pris une éprouvette
avec un milliard de ces bactéries pourri
pour céder suicidaire comme geste il a
bu comme ça bout en moins d'une semaine
ça n'a pas loupé il a développé un
ulcère gastrique
à binh et il l'a guéri quasi
immédiatement grâce aux antibiotiques
qui s'est lui-même prescrits malgré
cette démonstration comme assez
spectaculaire les scientifiques restent
incrédules ils remettent en cause la
validité du test parce qu'il aime il l'a
fait sur lui est ce que vraiment c'était
des bactéries dedans est ce qu'il y
avait vraiment le s qui avait vraiment
les bactéries dedans il a fallu 12 ans
dont deux ans plus tard des instances
scientifiques quand même pour un petit
peu le doute admettent que enfin oui
peut-être des antibiotiques serait le
bon traitement contre l'ulcère d'estomac
23 années plus tard 23 années plus tard
vous imagine je vous rappelle qu'on
parle du thé le timing il a fallu 23 ans
pour que marshall et warren reçoivent
enfin le prix nobel de médecine pour la
découverte de cette fameuse bactérie
donc hélico bac helicobacter pylori son
rôle dans les problèmes gastriques et
surtout dans les ulcères d'estomac donc
le timing est un ingrédient crucial du
succès et malheureusement oui
malheureusement on n'a pas beaucoup de
prise sur lui donc je vous ai présenté
quatre ingrédients du succès capter
travail talent ténacité timing bon bah
y'a le cinquième ingrédients mais je
vais vous dire comment il fonctionne le
sacré le cinquième ingrédients c'est la
chance on ne peut pas dire que il n'ya
jamais de chance avec un succès moi j'ai
eu suffisamment de chance et de
malchance dans ma carrière pour voir à
quel point il en fallait maintenant je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
la chance n'est pas toujours un immense
coup de bol comme par froid
d'abord la chance c'est toujours ce que
pensent les gens médiocres
quand ils voient que vous réussissez
parce que la jalousie les égards donc il
ya un poète qui disait une phrase que
j'aime bien
n'importe qui peut sympathiser avec les
souffrances d'un ami par contre
sympathisé avec ses succès exige une
nature très délicate
donc en réalité les gens qui réussissent
ils ont pas plus de chance que vous et
moi ils le disent d'ailleurs les grands
champions où les scientifiques vous dise
non j'ai pas s'ils n'ont pas le
sentiment d'avoir beaucoup de chance
mais c'est vrai parce qu'ils ne s'en
rendent pas compte
en fait il faut en sorte que la chance
les trouve mais ça c'est pas pareil du
tout la chance doit vous trouvez fait en
sorte qu'elle vous trouve le grand
spécialiste de la chance en france c'est
pas moi c'est philippe gabilliet qui
explique très bien ce phénomène et
regarder sa conférence ou lisez son
livre aux origines de la chance si en
général deux facteurs il ya une
rencontre
fortuite ou pas mais toujours une
rencontre d'ailleurs quand quelques en
quelqu'un a réusi vous lui dites quand
vous avez si bien réussi vous dit
j'étais un peu dans la merde et puis un
beau matin j'ai rencontré un tel parce
que ma voisine m'avait dit que trouver
un appartement c'est pareil c'est
souvent une rencontre donc ça c'est une
rencontre est la deuxième raison d'avoir
de la chance c'est une information et
désinformation
vous en avez cinq cents par jour le
problème c'est de les trier il faut
utiliser l'information
il faut que la chance vous trouve il
faut que cette information là vous
sachiez comment l'utiliser après m'avoir
écouté vous pourriez penser que que je
vous explique le succès mais que je
confonds c'est que la notoriété avec la
réussite parce que je vous parle de
grands sportifs de gens de gens
importants mais pas du tout les capter
dont je vous parle
ils sont valables pour tout le monde
pour tout le monde c'est un tableau de
bord c'est ce qu'on appelle les capi
live aux indicateurs de performance et
il est toujours en tête tous les mois
vous regardez combien j'ai travaillé ce
sujet est-ce que j'ai été assez tenace
est ce que j'ai pas arrêté
est ce qu est ce que le dernier cd que
j'ai pas envoyer clcv qui aurait pu
avoir mon stage alors prenons la
confiance que je viens de faire bon
exemple de conclusion est-ce que j'ai
consacré dix mille heures à mon sujet ah
bah oui ça j'ai largement consacré dix
mille heures à ce sujet puisque c'est
quasiment vingt ans de magie j'ai même
consacré beaucoup plus de dix mille
heures est ce que j'ai un talent ou un
don pour ce sujet absolument pas pas du
tout j'ai pas de don particulier pour ce
sujet par contre c'est un sujet qui me
passionne j'ai voulu le décortiquer et
donc j'ai vraiment consacré du temps
c'était ça le secret de mon implication
est-ce que j'ai été tenace oui je suis
très très tenace mais je suis tenace
parce que quelqu'un m'a dit parce que
j'ai lu le livre et je sais qu'il faut
être tenace pour réussir je suis pas
tenace par plaisir
ça m'amuse pas forcément d'être tenace
je préférais que les choses n'arrivent
plus vite et plus cuite dans la bouche
mais je suis tenace est ce que j'ai un
bon timing
non en ce moment j'ai pas un bon timing
ce que je vous dis là je pense que les
gens on voit des difficultés à
l'entendre à le comprendre il pense pas
que le succès peut s'apprendre et
d'ailleurs de toutes les conférences que
je fais c'est une conférence qui est
difficile à passer
parce que j'ai pas le bon timing
peut-être que dans dix ans on se dira ah
bah ouais ce mec il avait raison enfin
dans dix ans je serai vieux je m'en
foutrais complètement en ce moment les
esprits sont pas encore prêts à entendre
que le succès ça s'apprend et pourtant
j'en suis convaincu et puis surtout il
ya quelques mois que c'est physique
diaby et qui m'avait dit un truc mais
dit écoute laurent
je vais te dire un truc côté de la
chance n'était pas de la chance peu
importe toi tu considères tu as de la
chance
ok mais surtout soit la chance de
quelqu'un et même si vous m'écoutez et
vous dit vous n'êtes pas très chanceux
peu importe
soyez au moins la chance de quelqu'un
d'autre je vous souhaite bonne chance à
tous et surtout beaucoup de succès
maintenant que vous en connaissez les
règles
[Musique]